vraiment bien si nous on va super tu es
en forme et contre 5,6 bien et font
chier je sais qu'à un moment tu m'as
envoyé des sms je dis voilà qui monte
qui monte qui m'ont énervé que tu m'as
dit des fois cyril je vois là il
faudrait tout le monde ment baird la fin
tu me l'a dit ou pas non mais bien ce
que tu penses à arrêter bien sûr tu es
fatigué ça mais en fait moi j'ai pas
fais ce métier pour faire menacer de
mort donc ceux là c'est vrai que
j'aimerais que tu as pour s'arrêter ou
pas ouais et qu'est ce qui t'a pas fais
a fait part été écoutées avec des
conneries je peux je suis allé en disant
ça mais mes enfants m'ont dit mme banon
en fait tu vas rester à la maison
un look en fait ça m'a permis de sortir
non non mais c'est surtout tu vois j'ai
l'impression qu'à un moment ça un sas ça
sert à quoi c'est dur pour toi vraiment
est vraiment beaucoup menacée non mais
parce que c'est assez marrant enfin les
a menacés par qui en fait dix mois
écoute le gros problème c'est qu'à pad à
lire à partir du moment où tu fais un
spectacle comme le mien et que tu as
envie de vannes et tout le monde tout le
temps
et bah en fait tu trouves pas de
réconfort ce qui est plutôt une fierté
parce que je suis assez fasciné par les
humoristes qui arrive à être copain avec
les gens quoi parce qu'il ya donc les
légions de toutes les communautés en
veulent ouais mais ils m'en veulent
surtout ce que j'ai découvert récemment
c'est que depuis que j'ai pris un
engagement politique
pas forcément auprès de matheron c'est
pas la question tu vois mais en fait je
n'aime pas voir mon pays en fait ne pas
reconnaître des choses qui sont du
domaine de l'évidence tu veux manger
j'ai 38 ans j'ai fêté la coupe du monde
en 98
c'est génial black blanc beur maintenant
il faut qu'il y ait des patrons faut
qu'on soit au cac40 faut que un moment
tout ça devienne quelque chose d'évident
on est quand même le pays d'europe où il
ya le plus de mariages mixtes c'est le
passé n'a rien on n'est pas des anglais
on ne conçoit dans la rue on est tous
ensemble et surtout moi je fais des
vannes et qu'aujourd'hui un clown comme
moi ou mon analyste evancho benjamin me
disais ça tout à l'heure des mecs j'aime
voir mon spectacle comme marianne l'ont
fait en dix ans on spectacle ne met pas
les juifs ça m'a beaucoup vexé donc un
moment s'il ya des gens qui viennent qui
sont de mauvaise foi et qui finissent
par écrire des trucs qui sont pas vraies
derrière tu rentres dans une vraie
colère mais voilà frère on en a déjà
parlé il essaye à chaque fois de me
marginalisés c'est pour ça que j'ai
appelé spectacle en marge c'est
difficile beaucoup d'eau et d'attendre
en tournée ont été arrêtés par des
mairies en disant veut pas le recevoir
il est trop dangereux
donc je joue qu'à paris et les villes
dans lesquelles m
pourquoi discuter dangereux
bah parce que je pense que surtout j'ai
pas voilà je n'ai pas envie de courber
l'échiné quoi j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver
si moi aussi j'aurais rêvé d'être dans
le showbiz frv tep décor prochain avec
issa doumbia c'est pas la dernière que
j'ai choisi j'ai choisi voilà on les
égales pas mais quand tu grandis dans un
pays où il ya eu coluche et desproges et
que tu as envie de continuer sa
tradition de provocateur un moi j'adore
charlie hebdo j'adore hara kiri j'ai le
droit de dire que ça ne fait pas rire
c'est pas pour ça que je souhaite la
mort des gens mais tu vois maintenant tu
rentres dans une espèce et vous tous on
est des professionnels des médias dans
une folie c'est à dire que quand un
moment tu dis un truc il avait agonisé
pendant la pub
les gens sont très premier degré c'est à
dire que moi je me retrouve des fois sur
des plateaux télé ou moins dit oui là on
sait on a des preuves que vous êtes avec
les frères musulmans
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce discours
à désaxer mal quand tu vois des papiers
qui disent que tu es antisémite
ben ça me fait mal à partir au mans ça
serait effectivement j'avais
l'impression d'être des matches je te le
dis je n'aurais jamais invité un
antisémite le premier soir de radoub cas
j'ai déménagé des principes justes il
faut écouter ce qui dans ce spectacle il
n'y a pas une personne n'en prend plus
que que nous communauté les juifs les
arabes les blacks c'est très drôle et
c'est très intelligent effectivement
après si on prend ça pour me donner
certains vont dire wade et il est
entièrement il peut te tires anti juif
c'est c'est hallucinant que les gens qui
n'aiment pas le temps d'écouter ce qu'il
dit dans le spectacle mais ce qu'est ce
que tu dis sur les vtc
ça pourrait être pris très très mal il
dit voilà d'éviter saison ils ont deux
maillots du psg raw et maillot de
manchester en bas et la main droite sur
le son le coran ça peut choquer mais ces
deux mais c'est une façon de dire les
choses intelligentes mais sombre de même
ça m'a choqué parce qu'il ya un sketch
sur les parents qui frappent leurs
enfants et moi j'ai un copain drôle très
drôle
merci moi j'ai un copain qui est arrivé
à mehdi cautionne quand même les ors
parental mais c'est vrai que j'ai
l'impression qu'en toi tu fais un truc
qu'on comprend pas que c'est un sketch
non c'est vraiment ri c'est qu'on ne
veut pas accepter a déjà que c'est un
sketch et 2 potentiellement que ça peut
être drôle
moi ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui
c'est le règne des attachés de presse et
des bulles immobilières dans l'humour
c'est à dire que d'un coup on dit à cet
humoriste fatou va bien tu les reçoit il
est hyper marrant au bout de deux ans
dont on entend plus parler de lui c'est
un retour des années yéyé souvient le
mec qui sortent un vie
ouais ben course disait bill ou le mec
qui chantait la danse des canards on n'a
plus de nouvelles depuis 42 ans
la cub et voilà il ya ne l'a vécu moi je
suis hyper heureux d'être avec liane
foly parce qu'elle a traversé le temps
oui et je n'aime pas ces discours qui
disent ah oui mais ça c'est pas bien en
fait en france tu peux pas être
populaire à partir de tulle a vécu à
weather que d'un coup tu as des gens qui
disent si les gens aiment c'est que
c'est pas bon pour nous à bien si c'est
valable quand tu fais un succès au
cinéma
si ton film il est populaire et fait
plusieurs millions d'entrées les gens
disent c'est pas un bon film mais qu'est
ce tu me parles de ton film moldave qui
a fait 200 mille entrées et soufiane ça
fait autant que vous êtes dans le métier
tous les deux est-ce que vous avez
encore des potes dans le métier ou
est-ce que yacine tout le monde tu as
tourné le dos tout le monde dit ouais je
veux pas je veux pas fréquenter yassine
belattar parce que on sait jamais on dit
des trucs sur lui et j'ai pas envie
d'avoir un mauvais pas il ya des mecs
opaque et et jora mais voilà on est
quittes ont tourné le dos tu sais je
suis un je suis très comment dire
pragmatique ouais si tu attends pas
d'amitié t'es pas déçu
comme ça au moins c'est réglé je suis un
père de famille j'ai trois enfants
magnifiques
je suis hyper heureux d'avoir une paire
une vie de père de famille qui va
chercher ses enfants qui vit avec eux et
en fait passer du temps dans le showbiz
pour essayer de faire croire j'ai du
talent ça s'élèverait usurpateurs donc
aujourd'hui moi faire une storia
instagram art dubaï avec deux
influenceurs en dix ans les frères venez
voir mon spectacle
ça c'est de la triche je préfère comme
disait benjamin que les gens viennent
voir le spectacle et qu'ils disent
[ __ ] le mec j'avais un jugement sur
lui eh ben j'ai vu un truc qui m'a fait
rire que de commencer à faire des
amitiés parce que pardon te dire ça il
ya un joueur de foot que j'aime beaucoup
qui s'appelle adil rami a dit que ce
n'est pas les ayants footballeur mais la
réalité c'est qu'il était très copain
avec les gens dans le vestiaire et ça
lui a permis de gagner la coupe du monde
ou bien comme non mais je veux dire
parce que je les aime bien en plus
mais la réalité c'est dans l'humour
c'est pareil c'est que tu sais pas parce
que tu es dans une bande que forcément
derrière tu es quelqu'un de marans faire
rire les gens que les gens se déplacent
en plus avec une crise économique comme
aujourd'hui où ils vont donner 30 euros
ils vont aller dîner derrière ces 200
euros et que derrière tes pas drôle je
peux concevoir que les gens ce moment
ils en veulent à tous mes potes dans le
métier ou pas ouais bien sûr vrai quoi
ton atteinte à tabac un tabac jamin
tranier barbara matera niasséne au delà
d'un pote c'est voilà moi je suis très
déjà dire clanique ya des gens que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup je suis et même
des gens avec qui je parle plus en
embrouille
moi je suis hyper fier du moment qui
font carrière et qui réussissent n'ont
pas grand coeur après il faut pas qu'on
s'en voir des vies alors j'aimais
beaucoup les talent les collègues de
y est les gens il y avait des artistes
on est des affectifs
on rencontre 14e temps c'est mon frère
je vais l'appeler à 2 heures du matin
j'ai crevé sur le périph
il va pas venir flammes voilà c'est pas
faux vrai qu'au passé celui avec qui tu
joues d'un coup tordu la main ou pas du
tout si la dame est et non tu m'as pas
parce que ces publics mais par exemple
jamel debbouze n'a jamais proposé de
faire le marrakech du rire et c'est pas
grave qui garde le marrakech
je sais où et marrakech je suis
marrakchi j'irai faire rire des blagues
là bas mais moi je vais pas dire à jamel
que c'est mon copain pour pouvoir être
marrant là bas